monsieur le Premier Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur général mes chers
collègues nous procédons à présent à une
audition pour donner suite à l'enquête
de la Cour des comptes réalisées à la
demande de notre commission en
application du deuxième alinéa de
l'article 58 de la loi organique
relative aux lois de finances sur la
politique d'installation des nouveaux
agriculteurs et de transmission des
exploitations agricoles
le sujet se situe à la croisée des
chemins d'enjeux économiques et
environnementaux il trouve également une
résonance particulière en une période où
l'on parle beaucoup de souveraineté en
matière alimentaire le milieu agricole
n'étant certainement pas un marché du
travail comme les autres nous devons y
porter une attention particulière et
nous interroger sur le manque
d'attractivité des professions pourtant
essentielles parmi les leviers dont nous
disposons figurent des dispositifs
d'aide à l'installation des agriculteurs
dont l'efficience a été évaluée par la
Cour des comptes nous recevons donc son
premier président Monsieur Pierre
Moscovici qui nous présentera les
principales conclusions de cette enquête
il est accompagné par Madame Annie
Potter président de la deuxième chambre
de la Cour et des magistrats qui ont
préparé cette enquête je vous informe
par ailleurs du fait que les rapporteurs
spéciaux de la mission agriculture
alimentation forêt et affaires rurales
messieurs Vincent Ségouin et Patrice
Joly procéderont à une série d'audition
complémentaires afin d'entendre les
services du ministère de l'Agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire le
cabinet du ministre le syndicat jeunes
agriculteurs la FNSEA et l'assemblée
permanente des chambres d'agriculture
ces auditions au format rapporteur
seront ouvertes à celles et ceux d'entre
vous qui souhaiteraient y assister
après avoir entendu monsieur Moscovici
notre rapporteur spécial Vincent Segoin
présentera les principaux enseignements
qu'ils tirent de cette enquête à l'issue
des débats je demanderai aux membres de
la commission des finances leur accord
pour publier l'enquête remise par la
Cour des comptes je vous rappelle que
cette audition est retransmise sur le
site internet du Sénat monsieur
Moscovici je vous laisse à présent la
parole merci madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je change donc
de casquettes et de sujets passant du
Haut Conseil et la loi de programmation
militaire à la Cour des comptes et au
rapport de celle-ci relatif à la
politique d'installation des nouveaux
agriculteurs et transmissions des
exploitations agricoles j'ai toujours un
grand plaisir à vous retrouver je suis
heureux que cette audition nous sur
notre occasion sur un sujet aussi
délicat que passionnant qui comme vous
l'avez dit Madame présente concerne tous
en effet alors que plus de 40% des chefs
d'exploitation atteindront d'ici 10 ans
l'âge du départ en retraite la question
du maintien et du développement de notre
tissu agricole et crucial et je pense
que nous pouvons tous convenir que
celui-ci doit demeurer un outil au
service de production agricole dans un
contexte d'inflation des produits
alimentaires mais aussi nécessaire
transition écologique de notre modèle
vous nous avez saisi en janvier 2022 du
demande d'enquête sur l'installation des
agriculteurs sur le fondement de
l'article LO 58 2 de la loi organique du
1er août 1 c'est en effet le rôle de la
Cour de contribuer à votre contrôle sur
les dépenses publiques y compris dans un
domaine qui n'est pas facile à
appréhender comme celui de
l'installation des jeux agriculture un
peu loin des sujets dont nous sommes
coutumiers mais c'est une bonne chose et
nous sommes fiers d'avoir mené cette
enquête sont présents à mes côtés
seuls ceux qui ont mené à bien ce
travail de grande ampleur un hypoder
présente la deuxième chambre alors de
Coincy conseillère maître contre
rapporteur Nathalie Roland qu'on s'est
référendaire Guillaume brûlé
consulatoria grâce à eux la courbe
conduit ce travail complet que je crois
utile et je les en remercie aujourd'hui
je souhaite vous présenter les trois
principaux messages qu'il faut en
retenir le premier c'est que la
politique de renouvellement des
générations doit à la fois relever le
défi de la démographie mais aussi
accompagner l'évolution vers des modèles
et des pratiques d'agriculture durable
et résilientes le deuxième est que les
instruments d'aide à l'installation et
au démarrage demandaient adapté en ce
sens enfin notre rapport ma lumière
décide d'anticiper la transmission par
les cédants et de mieux tirer parti des
années qui précèdent leur fin d'activité
pour orienter
les transmissions vers des exploitations
durables
je commence naturellement par le prix
constat la politique de renouvellement
des générations se doit d'articuler deux
enjeux essentielles attirés de nouveaux
actifs agricoles et soutenir l'évolution
des modèles d'exploitation nous sommes
en effet confrontés à les enjeux
importants liés à la diminution et au
vieillissement de la population agricole
ainsi qu'à la baisse du nombre
d'exploitations
d'abord pressons rapide état des lieux
de la situation le déclin de la
population active agricole on le sait
c'est un phénomène ancien il y avait
plus de 2,5 millions d'exploitants de
1955 son nombre est passé en
20074000 à 496 millions 2020 lors du
dernier recensement agricole corollaire
de cette exploitation de cette évolution
le nombre d'exploitation agricole
diminue aussi fortement pour se situer
en France pétrolier à 389 000 en 2020 la
surface agricole utile se stabilise
quant à elle depuis le début des années
2000 ce qui signifie que la taille des
exploitations augmente mécaniquement est
aujourd'hui de 69 hectares en moyenne
contre 42 hectares en 2000 c'est
tendance
ou regard des données dont nous
disposons et des projections effectuées
sont appelées à se poursuivre quoi de
manière moins prononcée que par le passé
alors que comme je l'ai déjà souligné
43% des exploitants sont aujourd'hui
âgés de 50/50 ou plus et sont donc
susceptibles de partir en retraite ici à
2033 pour autant le devenir de notre
agriculture ne se laisse pas enfermer ou
résumer dans ces chiffres alors que
nombre de parties prenantes mentionnées
difficultés à transmettre ou s'installer
une étude de 2015 du mystère
l'agriculture sur les exploitations
concernées par le départ en retraite de
leur chef durant les années 2000 avait
montré que les exploitations CD
perdaient leur vocation agricole
seulement dans un cas sur 10 la moitié
d'entre elles est en reprise à
l'identique et 40% étant démantelé pour
agrandir ou pour créer de nouvelles
fermes par ailleurs on sait que le monde
agricole évolue avec le développement
des formes sociétaires
salariat à la main d'oeuvre externalisée
avec la diversification des activités
sur l'exploitation toutefois le modèle
d'exploitation dit familiale
c'est-à-dire un modèle économique ou
coïncide la propriété la réalisation du
travail le pouvoir de gestion des
décisions reste encore très majoritaire
dans notre pays et dans l'ensemble il
reste difficile de caractériser
l'ampleur des évolutions l'absence
d'études récentes sur le devenir des
exploitations lors des sessions et de
projections des flux de cessation
d'activité au seuil d'une décennie où le
nombre d'exploitants
croître pour ce qui est la cessation
d'activité la question qui se pose
l'échelle européenne comme nationale et
celle de savoir quelle sera demain le
visage de la culture et bien plus
largement du monde rural et des
territoires sujets qui vous préoccupe au
premier chef d'ailleurs la politique
d'installation des agriculteurs et de
transmission des exploitations telles
que les noms de notre code rural
comporte plusieurs objectifs
inséparables renouvellement des
générations production durabilité
sociale et environnementale aménagement
du territoire pour répondre à ce défi
l'aide à l'installation est le
renouvellement des générations sont des
priorités politiques qui sont désormais
clairement affirmées la Cour a examiné
la mise en oeuvre des quatre principaux
titres d'instruments prévus au niveau
européen et français mise en oeuvre par
l'État par les régions pas les autres
partenaires pour faciliter
l'installation et la transmission que
sont ces quatre types d'instruments
d'abord les subventions
pour soutenir l'installation et les
premières années d'activités de jeunes
agriculteurs sous forme d'aide direct ou
de soutien l'investissement ensuite les
aides fiscales les exonérations sociales
qui bénéficient principalement aux
jeunes agriculteurs attributaires de la
dotation jeune agriculteurs ou visant à
faciliter la transmission bon la
cessation d'activités et de la
repriseploitation troisièmement les
actions d'information et
d'accompagnement essentiellement portés
par le programme d'accompagnement à
l'installation et la transmission pour
financer par l'État et par les régions
pour aider les candidats à
l'installation à bâtir et
professionnaliser leurs projets ainsi
que les cédants anticiper leur
transmission enfin dernière instrument
c'est l'encadrement du marché foncier
agricole qui grâce aux instruments que
vous connaissez le contrôle des
structures et ça faire les beaux ruraux
régule les prix des terres et peuvent
favoriser l'installation des jeunes
ainsi
au plan national la loi d'avenir pour
l'agriculture du 13 octobre 2014 a
renforcé les moyens consacrer la
politesse en particulier le soutien aux
jeunes agriculteurs cette politique
inclut les objectifs pertinents
d'aménagement et développement des
territoires de diversification des
systèmes de production de soutien au
projet générateur de valeur ajoutée et
d'emploi ainsi que d'incitation la mise
en oeuvre de pratiques performantes
respectueuses de l'environnement de même
au niveau européen amplifiant les forces
engagés lors de la programmation
2014-2022 la programmation de la pacte
pour 2023 2027 définir un objectif qui
vise le site à attirer soutenir les jeux
agriculteurs et les autres nouveaux
agriculteurs à faciliter le
développement rural des entreprises dans
les zones rurales qui se traduit par
l'obligation pour chaque État membre de
consacrer au moins 3% des crédits des
deux piliers au soutien des jeunes
électeurs de moins de 40 ans pour la
France les moyens européens consacrés
aux jeunes agriculteurs s'élève ainsi à
environ 2 millions d'euros par an malgré
des objectifs affirmés et des moyens en
augmentation cette politique est marquée
par défaut de pilotage stratégique
national et régional ce défaut
s'explique en partie par le manque de
l'exploitable absente actualisation
d'études structurantes sur devenir des
exploitations mise en place partielle
des observatoires régionaux de la
l'installation transmission mise en
place absence de mise en place de
l'observatoire national prévu par le
haut d'avenir de 2014 connaissance très
imparfaite des biens à cédés de valeur
des exploitations du montant des
transactions impossibilité à
matérialiser les difficultés de cession
mentionnées par les parties prenantes il
s'explique également par l'attention
insuffisante portée à la stratégie et la
coordination des politiques par les
organes de gouvernance que sont le
Comité national de l'installation
transmission et les comités régionaux la
cour formule plusieurs recommandations
tribune pour lancer un appel à la
reprise de ces recommandations alors
suivies notre deuxième constat c'est que
les instruments d'aide à l'installation
au démarrage demandent à être adapté
notamment pour prendre en compte la
diversité de l'agriculture et des
profils des candidats d'installation
tout d'abord l'accompagnement à
l'installation est un dispositif qui
doit encore être adapté aux besoins
le programme d'accompagnement
l'installation la transmission en
agriculture la mise en oeuvre par l'État
par les régions et par des opérateurs
labellisés il est doté budget annuel en
moyenne de 20 millions d'euros par an en
2019 2021 or ce programme souffre de
plusieurs lacunes alors que se
diversifie l'origine familiale et
professionnelle des candidats
d'installation absence de dispositifs
consacrés à l'émergence des projets
inégales représentation des différents
types d'agriculture parmi les structures
chargées d'accueillir et de conseiller
les candidats d'installation manque
d'individuation des plans de
professionnels au titre des soutiens
financiers la dotation jeunes
agriculteurs aux jeunes agriculteurs
co-financés par le budget de l'État les
faux repas les régions et centrales même
si son impact sur décision
d'installation et sur la viabilité à
long terme l'exploitation n'est pas
démontrée pour tous les projets
agricoles ces conditions d'apprêter
d'attribution c'est à dire la
présentation d'un plan d'entreprise la
possession d'un niveau minimal de
formation apporte nous semble-t-il une
garantie sur la qualité des projets
soutenus en outre les aides
complémentaires auxquels le bénéfice de
cette dotations ouvre droit notamment
les examensations fiscales contribuent
également à faciliter l'installation
donc disons que c'est plutôt globalement
positif toutefois comme le Sénat l'avait
relever au moment de saisir la courbe de
ce travail nous constatons une nouvelle
fois comme vous que les objectifs de ce
recours à cette dotation joué avec toi
ne sont pas atteints car la moitié de la
population qui est éligible ne le
demande tout simplement pas les motifs
de ce manque d'intérêt on peut varier
depuis dernier travaux de la cour c'est
plus fondamentalement le ciblage de
l'ensemble des soutiens qui posent
problème puisque un tiers des
installations et le fait de personnes
âgées de plus de 40 ans en général des
personnes reconversion professionnelle
ces candidats de plus de 40 ans ne
peuvent accéder qu'à 9% des appuis
d'installation alors qu'il disposent
souvent d'idées novatrices et de fonds
propres et ton vieux à 40 ans vaste
débat je ne vais pas le demander au
sénateur ou au membre de la Cour des
comptes non plus d'ailleurs nous
relevons également que lorsque l'état
préparé en coordination avec les régions
sont plan stratégique national de mise
en œuvre de la nouvelle pacte les
soutiens l'installation ont été abordés
sous un angle budgétaire et non
stratégique la détermination du budget
consacrée à l'aide à l'installation et
ça impatient entre région défendez que
sur la poursuite des tendances
précédentes le budget consacré aux aides
complémentaires aux revenus pour les
jeunes adultes significativement relevés
et sans justification par rapport des
choix alternatifs par exemple
d'augmentation des aides à
l'investissement aucune analyse aucune
sur les avantages comparés les
différents types d'aides aide de
trésorerie aide à la production aide à
l'investissement n'a été réalisé par
ailleurs la délégation aux régions de la
gestion des aides depuis le 1er janvier
2023 ne sera pas sans effet sur la
politique d'installation des
incertitudes persistent
des décisions sont à prendre au plus
vite quand au niveau d'exigence des
engagements requis des bénéficiaires en
contrepartie de l'attribution de l'aide
à l'installation des jeunes enfin sa
légende des nouveaux agriculteurs
âgés de plus de 40 ans malgré la
création d'une aide spécifique au titre
du développement des entreprises en
milieu rurales le budget qui leur sera
considéré restera très marginal puisque
sera 4% de l'enveloppe des fonds
européens et des co-financement
nationaux et régionaux or je vais lui
dire représente une part beaucoup plus
significative des reprenants des
installations pour conclure sur ce
dispositifs nous relevons qu'alors que
démarre un nouveau cycle pack que les
régions voient leur pouvoir renforcer
ces dernières pourraient inutilement
veiller d'une part rééquilibrer les
dispositifs de soutien en faveur des
plus de 40 ans et d'autre part conserver
les critères d'élimité exigeants pour
l'attribution des aides vous aurez comme
nous relevé que lors de la présentation
du plan o effectuer les 30 mars dernier
le président de la République a
renouvelé l'annonce selon lesquelles les
aides à l'installation devraient
intégrer un diagn au sol adaptation
c'est une mesure qui reste à écrire mais
je pense que le constat qui est un site
délivré rejoint les le signal délivré
rejoint les constats et recommandations
de notre enquête donc je le mentionne
puisque c'est quelque chose que nous
avons nous-même écrit enfin notre
rapport mettons lumière la nécessité de
s'intéresser au long cours à la
transmissibilité des exploitations et de
mieux tirer parti des années qui
précèdent la fin d'activité des cédants
pour orienter le repreneur faire un
modèle durable en premier lieu après
avoir rappelé que pendant longtemps les
politiques publiques ont encouragé la
sortie d'activité des agriculteurs nous
faisons le constat partagé par les
parties prenantes dans l'ensemble que la
politique de transmission est
aujourd'hui insuffisamment investie et
essentiellement patrimonial dans leur
ensemble exception faite des mesures
fiscales les mesures proposées par
l'État dans le cas du programme
d'accompagnant nous sont utilisés que
pas très faible nombre de cédants pour
environ un million d'euros par an certes
les sessions d'information de conseils
de mise en relation entre ces dents et
candidats l'installation proposée par
les chants départementales
sont bien déployées sur le territoire
cependant elle concerne peu de monde et
leur porter apparaît donc modeste les
aides financières personnalisées sont
quant à utiliser de manière assez
anecdotique par ailleurs les sources
d'informations susceptibles d'éclairer
d'orienter les agriculteurs dans leur
projet de fin d'activité sont rares et
peu accessibles faut-il transmettre ou
démantelés faut-il accueillir un jeune
pour un tuilage faut-il transmettre un
ensemble ou garder une habitation le
champ des possibles pour répondre à ces
questions mériteraient d'être mieux
présenté
en fait on était discutés en effet nous
savons tous la transmission c'est un
moment sensible ou s'exprime des
préoccupations
patrimoniale voici la préoccupation
familiale des préoccupations
personnelles ou la prise en compte du
devenir agricole des terres n'est pas
aisé au milieu de tous ces choix en
deuxième lieu notre enquête a conduit à
souligner des phrases structurels
internes au monde agricoles pour
transmettre à s'installer les prix
complexes à fixer les exploitations la
transparence insuffisante du marché tout
ça favorise surtout le bouche à oreille
la possibilité pour les exploitations et
les équipements proposés d'être ni
d'adéquation avec les attentes ou les
moyens d'entrepreneurs mais aussi des
phénomènes de concurrence entre
installation de nouveaux agriculteurs et
agrandissements de fermes d'existence
j'ai dit que les deux pouvaient être
coexister dans le maintien en gros des
surfaces agricoles ces phénomènes
gagneraient à être prises en
considération et corrigée par les
exploitants en amont et tout au long des
activités de l'exploitation afin de
garantir en cas de retraite ou de
professionnels une meilleure
transmissibilité de celle-ci il devrait
être mieux pris en compte par les
politiques publiques en effet il
apparaît aujourd'hui probable qu'à
l'avenir l'activité agricole comme les
autres activités professionnelles ne
soient plus systématiquement le choix
toute une vie justifiant que les
agriculteurs appréhendent différemment
le fonctionnement et la transmissibilité
de leur appareil productif par ailleurs
le renouvellement des générations
rejoignant celui des pratiques il
convient de tirer le meilleur parti du
moment clé que constitue la préparation
de transmission pour accompagner les
agriculteurs et accélérer la mutation
agriculteur française enfin modèle
durable ça implique d'adapter
concrètement les instruments de
politique publique à l'ensemble des
objectifs de la politique d'installation
transmission enfin si cette politique
d'installation transmission présente un
intérêt national
sa conception et sa mise en oeuvre
nécessite évidemment d'être ancré à
l'échelle locale pour s'appuyer sur
toutes les parties prenantes tous les
outils pertinents moment où c'est ce qui
une nouvelle répartition des compétences
un nouvel équilibre entre les régions le
rapport recense des dispositifs et des
manières émergentes et je crois
intéressantes de travailler en
agriculture que les pouvoirs publics
peuvent utilement prendre en compte et
associés aux instruments plus classiques
de la politique d'installation
transmission nous pourrions poursuivre
longtemps sur ce sujet passionnant mais
il me faut conclure dans un contexte
évolutif une bonne coopération entre les
services de l'État et des régions
apparaît très souhaitable ce point de
vue la Cour relève que la réalisation
par les régions de bilan annuel de la
petite installation transmission prévue
par la loi contre 2023 devrait offrir à
condition que soit effectif une
visibilité nouvelle à cette politique
dans sa cohérence nationale comme dans
sa diversité régionale enfin
alors que la délégation de la gestion
des aides aux régions se mettent en
place et que le législateur sera très
prochainement appelé adapter les
contours de la politisation transmission
aux enjeux contemporains la Cour
souligne le caractère propice de ce
moment pour la mise en place autant
qu'il est possible de guichet unique
nécessaire pour assurer l'accessibilité
la cohérence des dispositifs
mobilisables par les électeurs concernés
tous ces constats approfondi que vous
trouverez dans le rapport qui était
livré réalisé à votre demande
conduisent la cour
identifier trois orientations avec des
recommandations opérationnelles
associées premier orientation c'est de
renforcer la connaissance des phénomènes
ainsi que la transparence et l'affinité
du marché pour cela nous recommandons de
mettre en place le réseau d'observatoire
régionaux l'installation transmission
alimentant l'observatoire national on
dit que ce n'était pas le cas et de
faire un bilan du fonctionnement des
répertoires départ installation pour en
améliorer l'utilité pouvoir constituer
une base nationale où il faut une
meilleure information c'est la base de
tout première rotation deuxièmement pour
renforcer l'ouverture du monde agricole
et à de nouveaux actifs à Lançon des
pratiques culturales nous proposons de
conditionner la désignation des
structures chargées du programme
d'accompagnement à l'installation et
transmission à l'engagement de nouer des
partenariats représentatifs des divers
modèles agricoles et donc contrôler le
respect enfin pour soutenir la
préparation la transmission
d'exploitation orientée d'un agriculture
durable pour tirer mieux parti des
années qui est précède la session nous
suggérons de renforcer l'accompagnement
des cédants qui envisage de transmettre
leur exploitation et non seulement de la
CD grâce à un guichet unique
pensant que c'est tout à fait clé que ce
débat soit accompagné voilà madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur
général mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
j'en ai terminé avec la présentation de
notre rapport je vous remercie de votre
attention et je me tiens avec les
magistrats qui m'entourent en
particulier avec la précédente poder
avec disposition pour répondre à vos
interrogations sur ce sujet
sensible ou sur des points que je n'ai
pas eu le temps de développer davantage
que la chambre connaît par définition
mieux que moi puisque ils ont réalisé ce
rapport attend et je pense dans les
conditions de qualité qui je l'espère
sont à même de vous satisfaire
merci beaucoup monsieur le Premier
Président de la Cour des comptes pour la
qualité de cette présentation et à
travers vous merci à l'ensemble des
magistrats qui ont contribué à réaliser
à répondre à cette à cet enquête qui
nous les conclusions sont très très
précieuses pour notre commission je vais
maintenant passer la parole Vincent
Segoin notre rapporteur spécial
merci Madame le présidente monsieur le
Premier Président de la Cour des comptes
chers collègues j'ai pris connaissance
avec intérêt de l'enquête qui nous a été
communiquée par la Cour des comptes et
de la présentation qui a été faite un
instant par son premier Président je me
permets d'associer mon collègue Patrice
Joly qui ne pouvait pas être présent
aujourd'hui mais qui partagent le
diagnostic posé par la Cour tout d'abord
je tiens à saluer le travail dont je
mesure la densité qui a été accomplie
nous sommes au Sénat bien placé pour
mesurer l'importance des enjeux en
matière agricole et de défi que
constitue l'installation des
agriculteurs comme la rappeler notre
collègue Sylvie mermillier un instant
qui va bien au-delà de la simple
question de l'accès à un secteur du
marché du travail
la complexité du sujet telle que je la
comparerais volontiers à une forme de
tectonique des plaques avec tout ce que
peuvent engendrer des forces qui ne vont
pas dans le même sens
il suffit pour s'en convaincre de relier
un article L1 du code rural et de la
pêche maritime qui liste des finalités
de la politique en faveur de la culture
et de l'alimentation pour mieux mesurer
le caractère presque inconciliable de
ces enjeux
compte tenu de la charge de travail
importantes que cela représente déjà et
en accord avec nous l'enquête de la Cour
a été circonscrite au seul instruments
de la politique d'installation de
transmission certains thèmes d'intérêts
indissociables de notre activité doivent
également être pris en compte dans une
optique de revalorisation globale
définir agricoles je ne voudrais pas
dresser un tableau à apocalyptique de la
situation mais entre les conditions de
travail pas toujours enviable une
rémunération globalement insuffisante
des enjeux environnementaux de plus en
plus prégnants sans compter la
concurrence de pays qui ne sont pas
soumis au même norme mais dont on a
n'importe les produits c'est l'ensemble
de la philosophie de notre politique
agricole qui doit être pensée
alors comment vendre son attractivité à
un secteur qui cumule tant de handicap
vous avez rappelé le contexte dans
lequel nous nous inscrivons je n'en
reviendrai pas sur ces points mais je
retiens trois caractéristiques
importantes cité dans votre enquête et
qui ont un impact sur notre politique de
soutien d'installation d'abord nous
connaissons globalement un déclin
continu de la population active agricole
avec toutefois un maintien des surfaces
agricoles util
ensuite le modèle d'exploitation
familiale demeure le plus répandu mais
laisse une place de plus en plus
importante à d'autres formes
d'organisations en raison du forme du
développement des formes sociétaires du
recours aux salariat ou à la main
d'oeuvre externalisée et à la
diversification des activités sur
l'exploitation sur ce point je me
réjouis de la philosophie globale de la
pacte 2023 2027 favorable à ce modèle
d'exploitation familiale enfin pour
favoriser les installations des
agriculteurs on ne peut pas faire
abstraction de certaines données
concernant les professionnels de
l'agriculture les agriculteurrices
représentent une part de moins en moins
importante de l'ensemble des
agriculteurs les agriculteurs sont de
plus en plus âgés et leurs revenus sont
de plus en plus décorrélés de leur
activité principale puisque en moyenne
seul le tien du revenu disponible moyen
des ménages agricoles provient d'une
activité agricole
afin d'atteindre l'un des objectifs
fixés par la programmation de la pacte
2023 2027 à savoir attirer et soutenir
les jeunes agriculteurs et les autres
nouveaux agriculteurs et faciliter le
développement durable des entreprises
dans les zones rurales je partage
l'analyse de la cour qui sent le
formuler ainsi nous fournit beaucoup
d'éléments indiquant que les dispositifs
actuels d'aide à l'installation ne
fonctionne pas de manière optimale
je n'insiste pas davantage sur ce que le
premier président a développé sur la
prise en compte de la diversité de
l'agriculture dans les mécanismes
d'installation sur la nécessité de mieux
connaître nos besoins et nos capacités
ni sur la nécessité de revoir la
politique de transmission aujourd'hui
essentiellement patrimoniale je suis
convaincu du fait que les
dysfonctionnements dysfonctionnements
pointés par la Couronne ne sont pas
liées à une insuffisance de moyens
d'ailleurs les crédits alloués à
l'installation des agriculteurs
augmentent constamment malheureusement
sans atteindre les objectifs
pour la seule aide installation des
jeunes agriculteurs et l'aide
complémentaires aux revenus nous
passerons progressivement de 243
millions d'euros en 2021 297 millions
d'euros en 2026 un autre élément qui
plaide dans ce sens et le faible
différenciel entre le taux de maintien
des installations et des après cinq ans
d'activité entre 98 et
99%. et le taux de maintien des
installations non aider qui sont à 90%
j'ai donc le sentiment que nous aboutons
des crédits en multipliant les
dispositifs parce que la réalité des
difficultés rencontrées est avérée sans
nous interroger sur une utilisation plus
efficiente votre enquête souligne
d'ailleurs que certaines évaluations de
crédit je cite n'ont été précédés ni
d'études prospectives ni d'analyse
stratégique en fonction des besoins
d'activité de production
identifier selon les filières et les
territoires
je n'ai pas jusqu'à parler de
saupoudrage mais il me semble assez
surprenant que l'on puisse réévaluer de
manière aussi substantielle des crédits
sans vraiment s'interroger sur leur
pertinence je partage donc les quatre
brigonisations de la cour qui vont dans
le sens de meilleures remontées
d'informations pour connaître les
besoins en matière d'installation
agricole et pour rendre plus accessible
et dispositifs existants mais il me
semble que tout ceci sera 20 tant que
l'on n'aura pas que clarifié ce que l'on
attend réellement de notre modèle
agricole notre dispositif actuel qui
consiste à soutenir un simultanément des
modèles opposés voire contradictoires et
à concataner des dispositifs qui se font
ensuite concurrence n'a aucun sens
notre temps étant contraint je n'aurai
que deux interrogations la cour la
première la Cour préconise de mettre en
place un réseau d'observatoire régionaux
alimentant l'observatoire national de
l'installation de transmission le mythe
selon un protocole commun de recueil des
données je partage totalement votre
analyse sur la nécessité de connaître
enfin régions par région les besoins
tant en termes de consommation que de
production je dois dire que cette
méconnaissance des pratiques et des
besoins agricoles de notre pays m'a un
peu surpris cela signifie-t-il que les
Chambres d'agriculture ne sont pas en
mesure d'assurer toutes les remontées
d'informations nécessaires c'est un
sentiment que j'ai eu en lisant votre
enquête les Chambres d'agriculture
apparaissent globalement un peu en
seconde plan et pas toujours en mesure
d'assurer leur mission en matière
d'installation mais je serai curieux
d'avoir votre sentiment sur ce point la
deuxième question je suis très favorable
à l'extension des dispositifs d'aide à
l'installation à destination des plus de
40 ans
de mon point de vue cet âge plafond pour
la DJA notamment à aujourd'hui moins de
sens pensez-vous que ce serait
envisageable un moyen constant pour le
formuler autrement avez-vous identifié
de potentiels sources d'économies dans
les nombreux dispositifs existants qui
pourraient être déployés vers l'aide à
l'installation de plus de 40 ans et
a-t-on une idée même approximatives de
ce que cette suppression du critère âge
pour écouter
merci monsieur le rapporteur spécial
pour cette analyse et ces questions je
passe la parole maintenant à notre
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances Jean-François ils sont merci
madame la Présidente je
remercie évidemment la cour pour ces
travaux notamment son premier président
mais toute l'équipe et me réjouir de la
du fait que le rapporteur spécial à
solliciter la cour pour les Clash et on
a moins l'habitude
d'entendre la cour sur je dirais des
analyses concernant
l'agriculture et pourtant notre modèle
agricole si tentait qu'il y en ait eu un
en tous les cas on voit bien comme
combien la culture a évolué en quelques
décennies se transformant complètement
entre le nombre d'exploitations l'âge
moyen l'origine de CDC qui s'installe et
dans ceux qui vivent ça a été rappelé je
crois que c'est par
Vincent Segoin la disparition enfin un
équilibre nouveau plutôt sur la place et
le rôle des femmes dans la culture mais
c'est pas l'objet de vos travaux l'objet
de vos travaux c'est de regarder de
quelle manière
effectivement
notre agriculture peut bénéficier de
modalités de financement et
d'accompagnement notamment à
l'installation et à l'installation là
aussi on va dire en trois décennies le
modèle d'installation a complètement
explosé c'est l'origine sociale c'est
l'âge moyen et puis c'est peut-être
aussi surtout la maîtrise foncière et la
manière dont les
candidats à l'installation peuvent avoir
plus ou moins facilement accès à
l'installation ce qui à mon avis pose
une question évidemment financière mais
pas seulement qui est une question
monsieur de société sur deux sociétés
sur ce que j'appellerai un peu la
souveraineté foncière nationale qui
mérite d'être interrogé des je n'en ai
pas en cause le modèle et le dispositif
des affaires mais je pense
qu'il est aujourd'hui temps de en tout
cas que c'est un moment opportun de se
poser des questions sur cette maîtrise
par rapport à des acteurs nouveaux
notamment sous forme sociétaire
notamment aussi sur l'apparition
d'investissement qui peuvent venir par
l'étranger on le voit un peu partout
dans des territoires assez contrastés
c'est peut-être sur des zones
frontalières mais ça peut être aussi sur
dans des territoires qui à deux prime
abord apparaissent aujourd'hui moins
accessible à ces investissements
financiers et étrangers et je pense
pourtant que c'est certainement un des
sujets les plus importants les questions
sont ouvertes des éléments de réponse
pas surtout sont apportés je crois que
c'est salutaire et que ça va nous aider
pour les mois et années qui viennent
notamment dans nos travaux budgétaires
merci monsieur le rapporteur général je
vais proposer dans un premier temps la
parole à Monsieur le Premier Président
pour la réponse à nous rapporteurs et
puis je ne veux pas oublier de saluer la
présence de notre collègue Jean-Claude
Tissot qui rapporte la commission des
affaires économiques et qui est présent
parmi nous ce matin monsieur le Premier
Président vous avez la parole merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Rapporteur spécial monsieur le
rapporteur général merci d'avoir de
l'accueil que vous faites ce rapport qui
je l'espère en effet permettra de
d'éclairer vos travaux
utilement
à vous écouter je conçois où je vois
qu'il y a une large convergence
d'analyses et je veux notamment
reprendre un point que vous évoquiez
monsieur le sénateur Segoin à savoir que
il s'agit pas essentiellement de
problèmes de moyens en tout cas c'est
pas ça que nous identifions dans notre
rapport ou ainsi beaucoup sur la
connaissance
on insiste sur le dialogue
l'ouverture et enfin sur
l'accompagnement qui sont dimensions
peut-être plus qualitative mais qui
permettent aussi d'une part de s'adapter
aux nouvelles formes de transmission
installation la diversité des
préoccupations qui peuvent être celles
aussi bien des aidants que des
installant et aussi à la modification du
modèle agricole que nous souhaitons vers
un modèle plus durable
après et donc ça soulève des questions
déficiences davantage que les questions
de moyens sur le rôle des chambres
d'agriculture il est variable selon les
territoires certaines sont ouvertes aux
partenariat certaines soutiennent
tous les types de projets elle
produisent et communique des
informations certaines ne respectent pas
leur cahier des charges donc on ne peut
pas n'avoir une leçon uniforme et voilà
forcément de territorisé ça n'invalite
pas la proposition de clouzon sur la
mise en place des observatoires qui
jusqu'à présent est resté pratiquement
l'être morte
nous recommandons de contrôler le
respect des engagements aussi des
chambres d'agriculture sur l'extension
de
au plus de 40 ans une hypothèse
maximaliste serait de compter les 5000
installés de plus de 40 ans avec une
aile moyenne de 25000 euros ça ferait
125 millions d'euros mais il y a des
solutions intermédiaires qui sont
possibles selon la volonté des régions
les régions pour arbitrer entre leur
dispositif je rappelle que le câble
était à fixé pour 23 2027 il me semble
toutefois que cette question rejoint
votre premier observation sur
l'efficience c'est-à-dire que dès lors
qu'on approche plus holistique de la
question
ce ne sont pas forcément des dépenses
additionnelles mais c'est peut-être une
répartition différente de la dépense qui
se fait et que un travail sur
l'efficience devrait permettre de
financer concrètement le surcroît que
représenterait cette prise en compte qui
nous apparaît en effet nécessaire parce
qu'elle correspond tout simplement à des
réalités sociologiques qui seraient
absurde d'ignorer oui de plus en plus de
plus de 40 ans qui est sur les
installant
un coup prédage de toute façon et pour
autant il bénéficie de très peu d'aide
ce qui dépassent dans une situation
moins favorable que que d'autres et donc
il faut il faut dire médié je pense
qu'on est fait c'est de la problématique
qui est la nôtre
merci monsieur le Premier Président donc
je vais maintenant passer la parole à
l'ensemble des
inscrits tout d'abord Michel cane puis
marque la mini merci madame la
Présidente je voudrais remercier les
magistrats de la Cour pour ce travail
intéressant sur l'agriculture tant qu'il
est vrai que c'est un secteur d'activité
absolument essentiel pour notre pays et
singulièrement bien sûr pour les
territoires alors j'observe par exemple
étant élus du Finistère certaines
convergences entre les analyses de la
cour et ce que j'observe moi dans le
département du Finistère on voit une
surface moyenne de 69 hectares au niveau
national dans le Finistère c'était en
2021 selon la grosse copie CERFRANCE de
76 hectares passés à 82 hectares en 2022
c'est dire que les choses évoluent
fortement et avec cela malgré une
diversité des formes d'agriculture il
faut bien le signal qui appelle aussi
peut-être des observations différentes
selon ces types d'agriculture quand même
une capitalisation extrêmement forte des
structures agricoles qui pénalise
justement la transmission des
entreprises et sans doute l'un des
facteurs les plus compliqués
et à cet égard pensez-vous que qu'il
faille par exemple recourir à des formes
différentes de propriétés des structures
agricoles par des collectivités par
exemple on parle beaucoup de fermer ou
alors par des investisseurs qui auraient
la capacité de pouvoir
investir massivement tant cette
capitalisation est extrêmement forte
vous évoquez
les perspectives un peu inquiétantes sur
la transmission c'est vrai que nous
avons dans le Finistère
7500 exploitations agricoles à comparer
aux 389 000 identifiés au plan national
il y a aujourd'hui dans le Finistère
autour de 120 candidats aidés à
l'installation chaque année c'est dire
que le delta est extrêmement large entre
le nombre de
exploitants partant à la retraite et
ceux qui s'installent même si un grand
nombre d'exploitants et je l'observe
aussi notamment sur des petits
structures sont
issus de reconversion professionnelle et
ne rentre pas dans les dans les chiffres
des données alors ma question là-dessus
c'est de savoir si vous avez aussi
analysé
les questions relatives à la formation
agricole parce que c'est quelque chose
d'important et en particulier les moyens
dédiés aux établissements
d'enseignements Agricole vous avez parlé
dans votre rapport vous évoquez la
nécessité d'une évolution vers une
agriculture durable et résiliente ça
passe notamment par
une formation qui soit adaptée dans les
établissements de formation permettant
cette évolution structurelle mais que
peut-on dire par exemple
de ces de cette évolution des effectifs
dans les établissements de formation
agricole on sait aussi que l'agriculture
souffre parfois d'une très mauvaise
image d'une part salle des pollutions et
ce n'est pas l'ancienne directrice
générale de la RS de Bretagne qui
me dira le contraire sans doute
il y a cet élément il y a le fait qu'on
y gagne difficilement sa vie et puis le
temps de travail comme l'évoquait tout à
l'heure leur apporteur spécial qui est
un peu hors norme par rapport à ceux qui
invoquent aujourd'hui dans notre société
donc tout ça ce sont des des facteurs
limitants sur lesquels il faudra que
l'on puisse regarder les choses alors
dans vos dans votre rapport vous évoquez
également la question de
l'accompagnement moi j'ai le sentiment
problème que malgré les évolutions
très forte la baisse très forte des
effectifs des Chambres d'Agriculture du
fait à la fois du plafonnement de leurs
ressources imposées par l'État et d'une
part et de la régionalisation d'autre
part j'ai l'impression que les effectifs
des chambres d'agriculture ont beaucoup
baissé peut-être est-ce l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles cet
accompagnement est un peu plus difficile
aujourd'hui malgré cela moi j'observe
que dans le Finistère il y a quand même
un accompagnement particulièrement
intéressant et
positif des des candidats à
l'installation par la Chambre
d'Agriculture il existe d'autres
structures aussi bien sûr notamment les
segments aujourd'hui dans l'agriculture
biologique par exemple et 10%
d'exploitation agricoles dans le
Finistère aujourd'hui ils sont
d'exploitation bio ou en conversion
c'est-à-dire l'évolution sur ce secteur
donc là on a peut-être des
interrogations sur cela il y a aussi
l'association Éloi par exemple qui
aujourd'hui accompagne donc il y a un
certain nombre de structures qui
existent et puis
dans votre conclusion vous évoquez aussi
la question du guichet unique et je
voudrais demander vous demander à quel
niveau vous pensez qu'il doit se situer
est-ce que c'est au niveau des champs de
la culture des organisations
professionnelles d'une part ou est-ce
que c'est
cela doit dépendre de l'État ou des
régions parce que finalement les régions
et les départements ont souvent des
politiques d'accompagnement des de
l'installation en agriculture les
régions d'autant plus qu'elles gèrent
une partie des fonds européens dédiés à
l'agriculture donc quelle doit être la
structure qui pourrait piloter ce que
vous appelez le guichet unique
merci Michel marque Lamini puis
Christine Lavarde oui merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le Premier
Président et l'ensemble des personnes de
la Cour des comptes qui ont travaillé
sur cette expertise liée au monde
agricole celui ont aussi le travail des
rapporteurs sur le rapporteur général
rapporteur Vincent second
je rejoins un peu une question qu'il a
posé j'anticiperai alors c'est sûr
certes
il y a un enjeu financier important on
est en commission des finances mais
certes il y a le volet humain vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le Premier
Président malheureusement la démographie
qui est là
baisse des effectifs mais de l'autre
côté concernant la contribu les
contributions publiques plus de 500
millions d'euros en 2021 alors il y a
sur la complexité des dossiers alors
parce que je crois que les questions de
fond c'est surtout les jeunes il y a des
jeunes qui sont volontaires mais on
s'aperçoit souvent je prends mon
département les Ardennes la complexité
des dossiers au plan de l'Europe
l'État les régions les collectifs boire
les collectivités l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales les
partenaires également alors cet enjeu
concernant le les modes de financement
et c'est vrai qu'on assiste souvent à
une
insuffisance de communication à ce
niveau là donc je pense que là il
faudrait le clarifier puis le rôle des
chambres d'agriculture je crois que les
Chambres d'agriculture
on partage parce que c'est vrai que les
effectifs malheureusement ont diminué
puis auparavant on nous avions dans les
services de l'État les directions
départementales de l'agriculture et de
la forêt qui est réellement les
agriculteurs maintenant c'est dans les
l'organisation des DDT et ça pose quand
même des problèmes de moyens humains
pour soutenir des dossiers qui sont de
plus en plus complexes dématérialisées
et puis aussi le lien avec les
experts-comptables les centres de
gestion
comment ceux qui chez unique pourrait
éventuellement bien fonctionner je vous
remercie
merci Marc Christine lavard depuis
Christian Billac merci madame la
Présidente alors effectivement moi ma
connaissance du domaine agricole est
certainement plus réduite que beaucoup
de mes collègues ici mais en écoutant
les propos du premier président et en
lisant la synthèse j'ai eu le sentiment
qu'on avait des politiques publiques qui
étaient un peu sectoriales et que on
vous entendant ce matin j'avais surtout
entendu parler finalement d'aménagement
du territoire et moins tant de tout ce
que l'agriculture pourrait apporter en
service écosystémique ou autre et je me
demandais si finalement ces aides à
l'installation elle devrait pas aussi
s'accompagner d'une d'une aide à la
transition du modèle agricole et on voit
bien en ce moment qu'il y a d'énormes
enjeux par exemple sur l'eau et est-ce
que demain un agriculteur doit se
réinstaller en tout cas reprendre une
installation de la même manière que
l'installation a été exploitée depuis
deux siècles ou est-ce qu'il faudrait
pas que ces aides elles puissent aussi
aider justement à la transition des
modèles à se dire qu'il faut voilà et je
j'ai pas eu l'impression d'entendre ça
alors peut-être parce que c'est dans le
rapport et que vous avez pas pu tout
nous dire mais et donc et donc du coup
de un peu plus loin dans quelle mesure
le gouvernement est moteur sur ces
sujets-là et est-ce que dans ce que vous
avez pu regarder la politique européenne
de la PAC et dans les évolutions de
cette politique cette dimension là est
aussi prise en compte merci Christine
Christian Billac puis Stéphane Sautarel
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Président mes chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur
de débats différents alors certes
avec au Conseil des finances publiques à
la Cour des comptes mais sur deux sujets
essentiels l'indépendance militaire et
là d'indépendance alimentaire parce que
je crois que il est important d'avoir
des canons mais s'il n'y a rien à
l'achète on pourra jamais gagner la
guerre
l'intendant je dois toujours suivre
depuis des années on a une bêche du
nombre d'exploitants on l'a vu divisé
par 5 en 7 décennies et une baisse de la
surface agricole utile aussi
on voit des parcelles abandonnés de plus
en plus dans toutes les régions de
France on voit des terres à l'abandon
vous avez une première question c'était
est-ce qu'on a des chiffres ou est-ce
que vous avez les chiffres de du
pourcentage de fil d'agriculteurs qui
perçoivent la DGA
est-ce que
il y a des noms agriculteurs qui parfois
DGA aussi essentiellement de file
d'agriculteurs qui repentent familiales
ça c'est la première question que je me
pose la deuxième question c'est
effectivement qu'il faut accompagner la
transition
par le formule consacrée par une
opération gagnant-gagnant entre le
vendeur et le repreneur je crois que
c'est c'est ça qu'il faut réfléchir
moi je m'interroge sur
la nécessité peut-être de mettre un
véritable plan national pour éviter ce
qui se passe trop souvent c'est la vente
à la découpe c'est à dire qu'on vend le
tracteur un collègue on vend trois
parcelles à un autre une parcelle en 4e
et puis à la fin il reste des parcelles
ce qui ne trouve pas acquéreur et qui
deviennent des qui sortent de la
récoltique il y avait des friches et je
crois qu'il faudrait essayer de mettre
en place le vrai accompagnement de la
solution effectivement je partage ça et
je m'interroge quand même parce que pour
avoir dans mon département en tout cas
mais je crois que c'est un peu pareil
partout si les régions et les
communautés de communes les
intercommunalités ont mis en place des
actions parce que leur compétences en
matière de lova économique sur son
artisanat sur le commerce sur
l'industrie il y a eu très peu
d'initiatives en faveur de l'agriculture
c'est à dire qu'on a beaucoup d'ateliers
relais dans nos domaines industriels
mais la ferme relais c'est quelque chose
qui est
assez peu répandu ça relève de
l'expérimental quand j'ai fait et c'est
infinité gigial et là ce qu'il faudrait
pas peut-être passer par un plan
national de transmission en impliquant
les régions et les intercours que la
compétences économique et l'agriculture
c'est quand même l'économie merci
Christian Stéphane sotarel puis Antoine
Lefebvre
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Premier Président
je vais juste faire un focus sur sur un
sujet qui a été notamment évoqué par le
rapporteur général qui est la question
du foncier que vous que vous pointez
dans votre rapport parmi les enjeux
parmi les freins mais qui en même temps
me semble pas suffisamment ou en tout
cas pas à la hauteur de ce que ça me
semble être un frein alors soit par la
régulation qui aujourd'hui pose des
difficultés soit par les questions de
portage soit pour tous les sujets
d'installation hors cadre familial qui
aujourd'hui effectivement se heurte bien
souvent à la question du foncier et
j'étais surpris de voir dans dans les
fringues que vous mentionnez dans votre
rapport ou dans la synthèse du moins que
les coûts d'installation étaient mal
connues et vous dites si le prix des
terres est connu et modéré les autres
éléments d'actifs sont difficiles
évaluer en termes de prix des termes
modérés je suis surpris de de lire ce
qualificatif
qui par ailleurs me semble un peu
contraire à l'autre frein que que vous
pointez du doigt et qui est réel sur
l'approche patrimoniale et l'approche
économique difficile à concilier et et
et justement cette question du foncier
du patrimonial me semblait être un des
principaux francs si on parle en termes
de rentabilité en termes de souveraineté
en termes de démarche économique et donc
je voulais juste vous vous interroger
sur les pistes possibles pour répondre à
cet enjeu qui me semble majeur et
notamment quant au portage et à la
régulation du foncier merci
merci
Antoine Lefebvre puis Jean-Claude Tissot
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Président mes chers collègues
moi je suis élu du département de
l'Aisne un département très agricole ou
toutes les productions sont présentes
avec deux AOC qui connaît bien la
présidente le champagne et le Maroilles
mais au-delà de ces AOC je partage bien
sûr l'inquiétude qui est exprimée dans
le rapport sur les difficultés de
l'installation y compris dans un
département où
l'agriculture avait toujours une place
très très forte et très dynamique
ma question elle est dans le cadre du
contrôle qui a été effectué par la Cour
avez-vous l'opportunité justement de
regarder ce qui se fait à l'étranger en
matière d'installation agricole la ferme
France est un peu spécifique mais il y
a-t-il des des expériences
significatives d'installation d'aide à
l'installation dans les autres pays que
vous auriez pu connaître merci merci
Antoine Jean-Claude
Tissot hauteur de la commission des
affaires économiques Jean-Marie maison
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Président d'abord merci pour
votre invitation
c'est avec plaisir que j'ai écouté votre
rapport ce rapport et je vais me
permettre je pense que vraiment c'est
une pierre angulaire qui pourrait servir
à imaginer le modèle agricole français
puisqu'on en est à lire tous les jours
des rapports sur la ferme France une PPL
qui va nous occuper bientôt ici au Sénat
on va parler aussi de la loi
d'orientation agricole ça va les
éléments que vous nous avez donnés vont
nous aider à réfléchir mais moi je
voudrais quand même on fait tous ce
constat de la difficulté de transmission
mais il y a quand même un élément de
base qui est factuel c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui très souvent le produit
ne peut plus l'outil c'est à dire
comment transmettre une exploitation qui
ne rapporte pas d'argent comment
transmettre une exploitation
qui ne oui qui n'apporte aucun dividende
qui ne permet quelquefois même
rendre impossible de rembourser
l'emprunt que le repreneur s'est
contraint de contracter donc c'est je
pense que c'est une question qu'il faut
qu'on se pose dès le départ
sur le modèle agricole aujourd'hui qui
existe et qu'on essaye de transmettre et
c'est pour ça que je parlais en début de
mon propos de nouveau modèle agricoles
qui permettrait à terme et certainement
pas au terme d'une génération ce qu'on
connaissait jusqu'à aujourd'hui où il y
a quelques années c'est à dire qu'avant
un agriculteur s'installait à 25 ans il
restait là jusqu'à 60 ans et il
transmettait à son fils ou à ses filles
ou à quelqu'un d'autre mais il
transmettait au terme d'une vie de
travail au sein d'une même exploitation
aujourd'hui on n'est plus du tout dans
ce modèle là et vous l'avez dit dans
votre propos monsieur le Premier
Président
les nos concitoyens changent de cursus
professionnel et finalement j'allais
dire presque quel que soit l'âge
ça peut être avant 40 ans mais c'est
aussi souvent après 40 ans et j'en veux
pour preuve les espaces tests qu'on
trouve sur nos territoires j'ai un
collègues qui en a parlé tout à l'heure
et ces espaces tests finalement sont des
tremplins qui permettent aux repreneurs
potentiels de s'installer pendant
quelques temps avec l'appui souvent des
collectivités et de la profession
agricole même si j'ai un poster mais
enfin souvent le soutien des
professionnels agricoles et qui qui au
terme de cette du temps de passer à cet
espace test disent finalement oui je
peux y aller je peux aller je peux
m'installer et donc ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que
faut-il toujours la barrière de l'âge où
est-ce qu'on peut réfléchir autrement se
dire finalement on aide la transmission
mais est-ce qu'on est de la structure à
se transmettre ou est-ce qu'on aide la
personne qui reprend cette structure
voilà c'est peut-être une autre
réflexion je la porte à votre
connaissance mais vous avez certainement
lui y penser donc voilà je pense que
c'est peut-être un autre modèle qu'il
faut qu'il faut qu'on imagine et puis
moi j'ai beaucoup aimé aussi sur le
propos que vous tenez quand on parle de
de transparence et de connaissance
d'exploitation à transmettre et moi pour
connaître bien le milieu parce que
c'était mon milieu pendant 25 ans
j'étais installé à mon compte sur une
exploitation agricole et je me rends et
pour avoir
des responsabilités au sein de ce milieu
là souvent mais très souvent pour ne pas
dire toujours quand on arrive dans les
commissions de contrôle de structure de
ce que vous voulez et accompagner dans
la structure que vous le souhaitez
souvent la faire est faite
souvent l'affaire est faite et c'est une
histoire d'initié c'est à dire que si
vous arrivez là alors en plus si vous
n'êtes pas dans le département concerné
vous arrivez d'un autre département et
que vous avez vu sur internet il y avait
une exploitation qui pouvait céder à tel
endroit tel montant très souvent ce que
j'aime pas mais vous arrivez juste pour
vous regarder
valider ce que les initiés locaux ont
décidé entre eux alors c'est un peu dur
en propos mais hélas c'est très très
souvent le cas donc moi je pense que la
transparence c'est une chose mais il
faut la transparence jusqu'au bout c'est
à dire faut pas seulement connaître la
structure il faut aussi se mettre autour
de la table avec la volonté de vouloir
installer quelqu'un d'autre
peut-être pas avec la même origine
peut-être pas avec la même imagination
que ce qui existait jusqu'à aujourd'hui
sur cette structure là
une ouverture d'esprit peut-être parce
que force est de constater que si on
continue de vouloir transmettre un
modèle agricole à bout de souffle
forcément forcément on fera toujours ce
même constat de se dire que nos
exploitations sont intransmissibles et
que la ferme France est en déclin merci
Monsieur Merci monsieur le rapporteur de
la commission des affaires économiques
et évolution des structures et des
modèles qui sera sans doute
forcée par les effets du réchauffement
climatique aussi je suis sur des terres
dans le Jura ou je des agriculteurs qui
se demandent si la production de compter
sera toujours possible dans quelques
décennies pour terminer Jean-Marie
maison
merci madame la Présidente merci à
Monsieur le Premier Vice-Président il y
a l'ensemble de ceux qui ont travaillé
sur ce rapport la France est un pays
agricole de longue date et depuis un peu
moins longtemps est aussi un pays
touristique
et la grille tourisme
est une formule d'activité qui se
développe beaucoup chez nos voisins je
pense en particulier à l'Italie
pensez-vous monsieur le Premier
Vice-Président le premier président
pardon que c'est une diversification qui
a de l'avenir et qui de nature a
facilité l'installation de nouveaux
agriculteurs il a donné de même si je
puis dire dans un autre
registre de l'énergie culture qui trouve
également un développement
important de notre pays merci
oui de réaction parce que en réalité ce
que ce que je note surtout et qui est
positif c'est que ce débat alimente le
débat alimente votre propre projection
c'est somme toute la vocation
essentielle de
de nos rapports faire la demande du
Parlement je vais pas d'ailleurs avoir
réponse à toutes les questions pour une
raison simple c'est que ce rapport
d'abord il suffit assez largement
lui-même il contient beaucoup
d'informations et surtout parce qu'en
fait
nous n'avons pas abordé tous les sujets
le chant du rapport il a été déterminé
avec les sénateurs qui sont à l'original
saisines monsieur Segoin sénateur de
l'ordre monsieur Joly c'est la
tolanievre et la Cour a proposé à partir
de dialogue avec eux je crois le
sénateur de couvrir l'ensemble de la
politique d'installation des
agriculteurs la transmission des
exploitations les sénateurs ayant
finalement fait étape de leur
préoccupations quant aux faibles taux de
recours à la dotation jeune agriculteur
c'est comme si là-dessus que le rapport
est centré donc il a pas réponse à tout
bien sûr n'est pas apparu souhaitable
d'aller au-delà de ce paramètre déjà
ample qui conduit à examiner à tirer pas
mal de fils de question nombreuses et
complexes comme le montre le rapport je
signale que la Cour réalisé un travail
sur le revenu éleveur qui sera
prochainement publié et qu'elle engage
une enquête sur la compétitivité de
l'agriculture française qui permettra
par exemple traiter les questions
évoquées par plusieurs sénateurs et de
derniers intervenants qui contribuant
avec les citoyens les pouvoirs publics
sur sur ces questions une sorte de
question madame
présidente puisse imaginer qu'il n'y
aura pas de compter dans quelques
décennies dans le Jura
pour l'ancienne élu de Franche-Comté que
je suis c'est vraiment là vous m'avez
porté un choc inadmissible et donc
vraiment que la Cour contribue à cette
question
j'observe une convergence entre
vos analyser et les nôtres par exemple
sur la capitalisation
des structures qui peut-être
accompagnées par de nouvelles formes
sociétaires et de financement peut aussi
avoir des solutions relais ou
intermédiaires de location du foncier de
l'appareil productif il faut utiliser
toutes les innovation organisationnelles
et financière disponible aussi de
développer de nouveaux collectifs de
travail
pense notamment la combinaison entre
l'exploitant et et le salarié
mais aussi interrogé sur la question de
l'accompagnement
en vous posant l'extérieur si avec la
baisse des effectifs des champs de la
culture l'accompagnement et pertinents
et il me semble que la Bretagne est
plutôt un bon exemple en la matière mais
en tout cas nous avons singularisé comme
tel de travailler efficace de chambre
d'agriculture avec notamment une
organisation régionale un guichet
d'accueil qui associe d'autres
organisations comme Agribio travail sur
l'émergence une association des
partenaires à l'information je dirais
pas que c'est c'est un modèle mais en
tout cas ça prouve que on peut faire
mieux avec une amélioration de
l'efficience il y a sûrement d'autres
cas je ne connais pas il y a les moyens
aussi importants et moins efficace donc
je rejoins le diagnostic qui est que ce
n'est pas la question des moyens qui est
primordial mais plutôt celle de de la
qualité du travail pour ce qui est le
guichet unique l'important c'est
l'adaptation locale
reviendra les tailles au collectivités
dans le cadre de la négociation en cours
et à venir de définir la meilleure
organisation entre la DDT et la chambre
pour ce qui est du rôle des champs
d'agriculture et des problèmes de moyens
demain les régions en fait vont jouer le
rôle des DT à elle de s'organiser et
d'organiser leur relation avec les
champs de l'agriculture et les autres
structures d'accompagnement d'où
l'importance également d'un suivi
national pour s'assurer qu'il est
homogénéité pour diffuser les bonnes
pratiques ça rejoint là les
recommandations que nous ont infinies
notre rapport pour ce qui est
l'adaptation au climat de toutes les
préoccupations agroal écologiques
une assemblée dans la présentation que
j'ai faite avoir souligné ce sujet qui
est notamment porté sur la troisième
partie
mais en tout cas le rapport est
là-dessus assez clair ça nous
orientations vont dans ce sens c'est à
dire des diagnostics agro
sur les risques sur le sol qui vont être
fait les plans d'entrevis doit tenir
compte de la durabilité environnementale
du modèle et je rappelle que c'est une
obligation européenne qui est inscrite
dans le plan stratégique national le PSN
qui met en œuvre la BAC en France donc
je pense que je suis dans la synthèse
c'est très clairement l'orientation de
ces travaux et vous avez raison de le
souligner de nous demander d'aller
fortement dans ce sens pour ce qui est
des fils d'agriculture dans la
transmission observons je le dis au
secteur Billac que des candidats hors
cadres familial leur nom aura progresser
de 26% à 34% du nombre de dégâts ce sont
les candidats ces candidats là qui
expliquent la hausse du nombre de Dja
donc bien sûr c'est un modèle qui reste
très important voire prépondérant mais
malgré tout il y a une diversification
qui est en train de se faire et pour ce
qui est d'éviter la découpe là encore
aux questions du secteur BIAC c'est bien
le sens du rapport qui est de proposer
un bouquet pour mieux accompagner
peut-être qu'un diagnostic
d'exploitation quelques années avant la
retraite avec une information sur le
dispositif avec des aides économiques au
cédant qui veulent transmettre et non
seulement vendre et une aide à l'accueil
de
de nouveau
agriculteurs des espaces tests tuilages
et encore une fois j'ai souligné ma
présentation j'espère suffisamment la
diversité des préoccupations qui
pouvaient être ceux du cédant et
nécessite d'anticiper précisément pour
éviter cette tendance néfaste que vous
souligniez pour conserver la surface
agricole et pour la faire muter vers la
durabilité qu'évoquée votre voisine pour
ce qui est des expériences étrangères
nous avons en effet regardé dans
plusieurs pays de regarder l'Italie
l'Espagne l'Allemagne le Danemark en
Espagne il y a une bonification pour les
jeunes agricultrices en Italie un
guichet unique pour les aidants
installations et l'investissement au
Danemark pas d'être compensatoire
uniquement une aide substantielle à
l'installation
un modèle qui nous est propre dans ce
contexte pour ce qui est de l'idée qu'il
y a un autre modèle à imaginer
se basant notamment sur les espaces
c'est bien le sens de nos
recommandations de favoriser les
partenariats avec toute la diversité des
structures accompagnement
avec des structures différentes comme
les espaces qui répondent à des profils
nouveaux donc qui sont très clairement
encouragés plusieurs d'entre vous ont
évoqué l'existence d'initiative locale
que les régions devront aussi prendre en
compte et mieux associer encore une fois
je n'ai pas répondu à toutes vos
questions certaines sont dans le rapport
d'autres sont autres rapports d'autres
sont des contributions de la cour seront
toujours disponibles pour participer à
vos travaux et je dois dire je parle de
contrôle à présidente et des équipes que
ça c'était un travail pratiquement
intéressant et enrichissant comme
beaucoup de sucres parce que en effet
j'ai pas fini de la métaphore comme le
serpillac sur
l'indépendance stratégique et
l'indépendance alimentaire mais c'est un
sujet tout à fait fondamental on a en
effet divisé par 5 le nombre
d'agriculteurs depuis
70 ans c'était d'ailleurs un objectif de
la Pâques en réalité qui était de
permettre de faire muter le modèle
en bon ordre en gardant une même en
enrichissant la production agricole mais
il y a aussi sans doute un minimum une
somme pas loin d'y être il y a des
choses à conserver il y a des mutations
accompagnées il faut le faire en gardant
l'avenir c'est effectivement cette
durabilité et en ayant la préoccupation
des hommes et des femmes dans les cédant
que les installant avec les trois
orientations que que nous avons souligné
j'espère que ce rapport permettra en
effet c'était dit par plusieurs de
réfléchir au modèle agricole de demain
et la course sera très heureuse de
continuer à contribuer à cette réflexion
merci monsieur le Premier Président je
renouvelle non merciment à l'ensemble de
la Cour des comptes je vous propose
chers collègues d'autoriser la
publication de l'enquête de la Cour des
comptes en annexe au rapport
d'information des rapports spéciaux
merci à toutes et tous de votre intérêt
sur ce sujet et j'imagine bien que cette
enquête va étayer d'autres propos par la
suite grand merci à l'ensemble de la
Cour des comptes nous allons poursuivre
chers